[Applause]
eight to shoot for chris paul
devin book is at half court talking to
the fans paul for three puts it in 118
and 92 the suns have blown it open 37
points for paul
booker talking to the fans understanding
we've seen this movie before
we have an issue on the court right now
between both teams but chris paul
beverly and chris paul
beverly and paul after knocking down
that shot
this is now live as beverly
and paul get it to look like some kind
of pushing match
as the players are going to their
respective benches after the timeout was
called
[Applause]
oh what i mean
that's as unsportsmanlike as it gets
patrick beverly losing control
he said something depaul said something
to him and he
reacted inappropriately we've been
chirping all series long now's not the
time to react that way
upon video review it has been determined
that petrol checked it
and assessed the technical fire phoenix
will shoot one free throw
and then la's ball
six but patrick beverly after walking
past chris paul and it doesn't look like
he says anything to him
beverly just losing control of his
emotions he's been ejected from the game
call for a technical foul
you know beverly has been had such a
great impact in this series to have it
marred by
getting thrown out in the game now
granted it's a 26 point game but just no
place
in the game for that it's been a
hard-fought series these teams have gone
at each other
and beverly just losing control you've
been talking trash the whole time you've
been doing an outstanding job
defending devon booker defending chris
paul talking trash when you get stops
bottom line is it ain't no fun when the
rabbit got the gun and chris paul is
rolling right now